[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام هل تهدف
اصلاحات رئيس الحكومه العراقيه حيدر
العبادي الى مكافحه الفساد حقا ام انها
جاءت فقط لامتصاص غضب جماهيري عارم هل ما
يجري في العراق حاليا مجرد لعبه سياسيه
يقودها اللوردات الفساد ضد بعضهم بعضا ام
انها هبه
عابره هل جاء توقيت المظاهرات مناسبا
للحكومه العراقيه التي تحاول اخفاء
خسائرها امام تنظيم الدوله وقد تكون هي من
اجج شراره هذه الاحتجاجات يتساءل البعض
اين كانت المرجعيات الدينيه التي تطالب
حيدر العبادي حاليا بمحاربه الفساد هل
تفعل ذلك خشيه ثوره شعبيه تطيح بحكم رجال
الدين وبف
سدهم لكن في المقابل اليس الشعب العراقي
بكل طوائفه متضررا من سياسه الفساد
والافساد
التي تمارسها الطبقه الحاكمه منذ سنوات
اليست المظاهرات الجديده بدايه ثوره
عارمه الم تنهب خزائن العراق وتنفق عشرات
مليارات الدولارات على ملف الطاقه وده
فيما لا يزال العراق يتخبط في الظلام ويكت
توي بدرجات حراره غير مسبوقه الا يواجه
نظام المحاصصه الذي افرز لصوصا من الوزراء
الذين جمعوا ث رت طائله وتسببوا في تردي
الخدمات الاساسيه للمواطنين الا يواجه
اليوم تحديا قويا بحكم وطنيه شعارات
المتظاهرين وتحررها من اكراهات الساسه
والدين كما يرى
مراقبون الم تحاول بعض التيارات الدينيه
والسياسيه ركوب الموجه من خلال اعلانها
تاييدها لمطالب المحتجين بهدف احداث
انقسام بينهم اسئله نطرحها على هوائ
مباشره على الكاتب والباحث السياسي السييد
داوود البصري وعبر الاخبار الاصطناعيه من
لندن الكاتب والاعلامي علاء الخطيب نبدا
نقاشنا بعد هذا الفاصل القصير فابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام
وموضوعنا الفساد في العراق نبدا اولا مع
الكاتب والبحث السياسي داوود البصري
استمعت اليوم الى قرار البرلمان وقد صادق
على اصلاحات رئيس الحكومه حيدر العبادي في
مكافحه الفساد البعض يقول ليس ذلك الا من
اجل امتصاص غضب الشارع العراقي كيف تقرا
في هذه الخطوه موافقه البرلمان العراقي
بحد ذاته هذا قرار مثير للسخريه والتندر
لكون البرلمان هذا بحد ذاته هو اكبر
بالوعه فساد في العراق كل الفاسدين
والمفسدين يتمركزون ويتوقعون في هذا
البرلمان هذا البرلمان ما هو الا ما هو
الا انبوبه اختبار للفساد الحقيقي القائم
في العراق الفساد في العراق عباره عن
امبراطوريه امبراطوريه كامله متكامله
الاركان حيدر العبادي واجراءات حيدر
العبادي مجرد اجراءات ترقيع عابره لا تعبر
عن حقيقه الموقف ولا يمكن باي حال من
الاحوال ان تمس الفساد او المفسدين لان
رئيس الفساد وزعيم الفساد وسيد الفساد
وقائد الفساد المختار نور المالكي لا يزال
حرا طليقا كل المصائب التي حدثت في العراق
وانتشار داعش وماع وغيرها من الجرائم
والمجازر التي جرت وراها حكومه نور
المالكي السابقه التي اورثت العراق مورد
الهلاك ودمرت العراق وهشم اقتصاد العراق
وسمحت لوزراء اللصوص من حزب الدعوه الحاكم
بالهروب وعدم المتابعه ما يحصل ما يقرره
البرلمان لا يعبر الا عن حاله هروب الى
الامام وما هو الا محاوله لذر رمات في
العيون لان هذا البرلمان كما اسلفت برلمان
معبا بالحرامي واللصوص وحتى الشعب العراقي
في مظاهرات الاخيره في ساحه التحرير او في
المدن العراقيه الاخرى وبالذات مدن الجنوب
العراقي بين قوسين الشيعيه انتفضت ضد هذا
البرلمان الذي لا يعبر عن مصالح الفقراء
والمستضعفين في العراق لقد سبق لجماهير
العراقيه في المحافظات السته الغربيه
والشماليه ان انتفضت وان عبرت عن موقفها
في عام 2013 وطالبت بمواقف واضحه وصريحه
لمعالجه الخلل والفساد في في اروقه السلطه
وفي اززه الدوله ولكن للاسف جابها نور
المالكي بالدم والحديد والنار ووصفهم
بالفقاعات بينما الفقاعه الحقيقيه وحزب
الدعوه ومجموعه الاحزاب الايرانيه
والفقاعه الفعليه وهذا البرلمان التافه
السخيف الذي هو برلمان الصوص لا اكثر ولا
اقل لذلك لا فائده ترجى من اي قرارات طيب
لا فائده فائده ترجى من هذه القرارات ربما
استمعت السيد علاء في في لندن ويعني وصف
هذه
ال القرارات وا الاصلاحيه التي اقرها
البرلمان بانها يعني تابعه للامبراطوريه
فساد كيف
ترد تحيه لك استاذ جمال ولضيفك الكريم
وللمشاهدة
بالتاكيد هذه التظاهرات كانت تظاهرات
العراقيين هي ثوره العراقيين ضد الفساد ضد
الطبقه الفاشله ضد كل ما هو فاشل في
الحكومه العراقيه ولكن ليس ضد النظام
السياسي وهذا معلوم تماما لكل القاصي
للقاصي والداني وبالتاكيد لذلك انه
الاعلام العربي قد غطى على هذه التظاهرات
وكل الحكومات العربيه لم تنبت ببنت شفا
اتجاه هذه التظاهرات وحتى الولايات
المتحده لم تبدي اي راي اتجاه هذه
المظاهرات وبالتالي هذه المظاهرات هي لا
تروق للاقليم العربي لانه نبعت من الشارع
العراقي وبالتالي هي كانت ثائره ضد الفساد
وثوره ضد الفساد هذه الاصلاحات التي جاءت
وحزمه الاصلاحات التي اطلقها السييد حيدر
العبادي كانت بضغط من الشارع العراقي لم
يكن حقيقه باراده السياسيين حتى تقول انها
مهزله او مسرحيه او الى ذلك ولكن كانت
باراده باراده الشارع العراقي الشارع هو
من فرض وحقيقه كانت هناك نتائج باهره
وكبيره جدا لاول مره في تاريخ البرلمان
العراقي يصوت 297 عضو من مجموع 325 عضو
قسم من عندهم كانوا غائبين وقسم مرضى لكن
هناك اطباق على محاربه الفساد من قبل
العراقيين النواب الذين صوتوا اليوم اعتقد
انهم صوتوا بالاجبار اجبار الشارع العراقي
جعلهم يصوتون وكذلك حتى حزمه الاصلاحات
التي نادى بها السيد رئيس الوزراء كانت
ضمن مطالب الجماهير هذه المظاهرات في
الحقيقه كانت مظاهرات وطنيه بحته اولا لم
ترفع هذه المظاهرات اي شعار طائفي هذه
المظاهرات لم تمس اي مؤسسه حكوميه هذه
المظاهرات لم تعتدي على رجال الامن هذه
المظاهرات لم تقطع
طريقا يؤدي الى مصلحه الناس هذه المظاهرات
لم تسمي قوى الامن بنعود طائفيه لذلك لا
يمكن حقيقه ان نوهم الشارع العربي والشارع
العراقي بان ما حدث في الانبار وصلاح
الدين او ما يسمى بساحات الاعتصام هي نفس
هذه المظاهرات هذه مختلفه تماما هذه
المظاه
طري
يكون
الوقت نقطه مهمه هنا قلت نقطه مهمه
جدا سسي هذا كلام خطير البعض
يقول
المت
السمين حينما خرجنا الى
ساح الاسلوب الله يخليك الجماهير اللي
خرجت في بغداد وفي المحافظات الاخرى وحتى
في المد الجنوبيه
انا ارد سياسي وبعيد عن الطائفيه وبعيده
عن الدعايه والدماغيه الجماهير طالبت بحل
البرلمان طالبت بحل البرلمان السياسيه
وجد
الستوري اقول
مره لان الحكومه العراقيه وان رئيس
الحكومه
العراقيه اكذوبه الاعلام العربي وخصوصا
الجت
الع
العراقيه نحن نتحدث عن الفد والقرارات
التي صدرت هذا اليوم فيما يتعلق بالفساد
في العراق نحن لا نتحدث عن الجزيره
الجزيره منبر اعلامي كانت الناس في السابق
تفرق بين اسود وابيض الان تفرخ بسبب
الجزيره وتعرف اطياف الالوان في الشارع
العربي كله ارجوك لا تتعرض للجزيره نبقى
في
موضوعنا في موضوعنا لو سمحت لنبقى في
موضوعنا لماذا ايك الدور يا سيد علاء سيد
علاء ساعطيك الدور ارجوك سيد علاء يقول لك
انه هذه التظاهرات كانت ضد النظام السياسي
انت تقول بانها ليست ضد النظام السياسي
هذا كلام خطير المتظاهرون يريدون ايجاد
وتجديد نظام سياسي جديد بالعراق بعد ان
انسحب الامريكيون لكي يجمع كل اطياف الشعب
العراقي معا لماذا يبقى الشعب العراقي في
الخارج انت تجلس في
لنقص السيد داود يجلس هنا وربما لا اعرف
اين تقيم العراقيون مشتتون الى متى يبقى
العراق على وضع هذا ان لم يكن
هناك اعاده تجديد للخطاب السياسي وللنظام
السياسي في العراق العراق لن يتقدم تفضل
سيدي لك سيد داود الطبقه السياسيه في
العراق وصلت الى طريق مسدود ووصلت الى
حافه نهايات خطيره العراق الان ضائع ثلث
العراق تحت الاحتلال الجماعات الارهابيه
سواء كانت من داعش او حتى الجماعات
الايرانيه العراق الان يعيش في ازمه
حقيقيه لا يمكن لهذه الحكومه ان تستمر ولا
يمكن لهذا البرلمان الذي يعيش في المنطقه
الغبراء ان يعبر عن حقيقه الشارع العراقي
الشارع العراقي ثار وانتفى ضد العمليه
السياسيه وضد المحاصصه وضد الطائفيه وضد
تدخل المرجعيات الصنم بالسياسه العراقيون
احرار العراقيون ليسوا عبيد لمراجع اجنبيه
لا
يتكلمون العراقيون يحاولون حل مشاكلهم
بانفسهم الاخ علاء الخطيب
اي طيب لماذا لا تبادروا انتم عفوا لماذا
لا تبادروا انتم من اجل مصالحه وطنيه في
العراق يعني هو ربما الطرف هذاك يريد
الغاء الغاء الطرف الاخر انتم من جانبكم
هل تقبلون بالطرف الثاني العراق واقع تحت
محاور قوه العراق واقع تحت ضغط ايراني
شديد الان الجماعات الايرانيه متوثب
وتحاول الانقضاض على السلطه هنالك محاولات
عديده الانقلابات ميليشياوي على العمليه
السياسيه ذاتها الاحزاب الحاكمه الاحزاب
الطائفيه الحاكمه ليست متفقه على برنامج
واحد بالعكس تعيش خلافات ذاتيه رهيبه ه
تريد ان تقول ان هناك تصدع في داخل النظام
الحاكم في العراق خاصه في يت متفق اصلا
مصدعين من البدايه للنهايه هنالك عداء
شخصي وهنالك عداءات من ايام المعارضه
العراقيه وهنالك وم هنا ومن هنا جاءت
الاصلاحات التي اودت بثلاث مناصب عليا في
الدوله الاصلاحات لا تعني شيء كما قلت ليس
الاصلاحات وانما اجراءات ترقيع لا تعبر عن
متغير حقيقي اجراءات ترقيع لتوفير
الميزانيه لان الدوله العراقيه تعاني من
افلاس افلاس تام كانوا يتحدثون ق الم
الارهابيه
يرير الوجوه
الفاسده
الفاس الوجوه الكالح
اسمحي حتى هناك خلل في العلاقه بين
كردستان يجب ان تصحح هناك هناك خلل حقيقي
في العمليه السياسيه الخلل الذي اوصله ليس
هي ليس فقط يعني حقيقه ما تقوله انت تذب
اليوم الذب الوش على هذا وذب الوش على ذاك
ابدا تقيه
السياسيه تقصد هنا بالعمليه السياسيه هل
تقصد اشخاص ام تقصد بنيويه العمل السيا
ليس هنا ليس هناك شخص مقدس يا سيدي في
العمليه السياسيه اليوم اليوم الشارع
العراقي هو بيده زمام المبادره انا حقيقه
اتعجب واعجب من كل حتى اعجب من كل
الكتاب والاعلام العربي والفضائيات الكل
كانوا ينادون بالغاء المحاصصه والتغيير
وتغيير هذه الوجوه عندما انتفض الشارع
العراقي اليوم يريد ان يغير المحاصصه يريد
ان يقتلع هذه المعادله الفاسده تقولون
عليه انها عباره
عن ليس لها اول ولا اخر نعم النظام
السياسي الديمقراطي الديمقراطيه اساس نحن
الذين حقيقه انتخبنا ان يكون النظام في
العراق نظاما ديمقراطيا نوريا لا ند
العوده الى الكوريه تسمي العبث السائ في
العراق هو نع من الديمقراطيه اسمح لي يا
سيدي الذي يسود في العراق لا علاقه له
بالديمقراطيه له علاقه بالفوضي الحقيقيه
وبمي الشويه وعصابات المسلحه التي تقت الم
اسمحي
اسح بالعلمانيه اسمحي يا استاذ داوود يا
استاذ داوود حتى الملتحين بالعلمانيه حتى
الملتحين بالعلمانيه هؤلاء الذين صدعوا
انسنا يوميا بيقولون بنريد حكم مدني في
العراق ونريد كذا ونريد كذا يعني السيد
اياد علاوي يصرح ضد ضد المظاهرات مع انه
صدع رؤوسنا على انه يريد يقتلع هذه
المعادله تعال اقتلع هذه
المعادله
هؤلاء الذين تضرروا من خلال المظاهرات هم
الان صد المظاهرات يعني السيد اسامه
النجيفي والسيد علاوي واخرين كل هؤلاء الي
المظهرين لم تق نور المالكي وحتى المالكي
يا سيدي من قال قال السؤال سابقى معك سي
سيد علاء سابقى معك الان تقول وانت سعيد
جدا بهذه القرارات التي صدرت هل ستحاسب
المفسدين ام ستوقف فقط المفسدين ويعودوا
من جديد من الباب الخللا ستحاسب
المفسدين بما فيهم لا لا لا ابدا ستحاسب
المفسدين لا لا ستحاسب المفسدين يا سيدي
انت لا ترك لا تركز على شخصيه معينه لانه
هذا يعني يتجه باتجاه
اخر المفسدون المفسدون هم اسمح لي استاذ
جمال المفسدون كرد شيعه سنه تركمان كل كل
من موجود حقيقه اليوم على راس السلطه وهو
وهو نافذ وهو يستخدم السلطه لاغراض الخاصه
فهو فاسد لهذا هذا كلام خطير هذا كلام
جديد انا اسمعه من الضيف اريد اريد ردا
منك سيد داوود على الموضوع هذا يعني فساد
العمليه السياسيه اساسا ويعني العمليه
السياسيه قامت على اسس خاطئه منذ البدايه
الدستور كتبه بريمر وكتبه بالتوافق مع
المرجعيه الدينيه وكتبه بالتوافق مع
الدستور العراقي كان نص امريكي جاهز مع
الاسف وك كسه كرس حلاه الانقسام المجتمعي
وكرس الطائفيه واسس لل المحاصصه ول دوله
المحاصصه التي وصلت الى نهايتها الحاليه
نهايه الحاليه وصلت لماذا بعد افلاس
الاحزاب الاحزاب الطائفيه افلست بالكامل
الاحزاب لم تقدم سصو سيد داود سيد داود
المرجعات الدينيه طالبت حيدر العبادي
بمحاربه الفساد هذه حقيقه هل تفعل ذلك
برايك خشيه ثوره شعبيه تطيح بحكم رجال
الدين و بفساده واين كانت هذه المرجعيه
طيله 12 عام من حكم السلطه الفاسده واين
كانت هذه المرجعيه من مطالب جماهير في
المحافظات المنفضه اللي سماها ساحات
التامر بينما ساحات العز والكرامه لو طبقت
المواد 14 اللي طالبت بها
جماهيرك يقول لك انه كل كل الشعب العراقي
يقول لك بكل طوائفه متضرر من سياسه الفساد
والافساد لم يوفر احدا وكانوا سنه العراق
هم الطليعه النضال الطليعه النضال من اجل
قياده التغيير لكن مع الاسف هنالك روح
طائفيه بغيضه داخل السلطه يقودها قائد
النشاله
لا اهمك
بالطائف سيد علاء هل العراق العراق انت
تري
تريديه لحد الان لم
ي ش ولم يعتدوا على قوى الامن واسسوا
لعلاقه بين رجال الامن وبين المتظاهرين
هذه علاقه جديده في الدول
العربيه رجل رجل سي يا سيد علاء س سي
علا ما بدك تحترمنا شوي يا سيد علاء انا
بطرح عليك
سؤال يا رجل اسمعني بس اطرح عليك سؤال ق
انت قلت يجب ترميم العمليه السياسيه في
العراق هل ذلك سيطيح وهذه القرارات التي
صدرت باركها المالكي وغيره هل فعلا هؤلاء
لن يعودوا من الباب الخلفي هنا
السؤال يا سيدي يا سيدي هذا ما يقرره
الجماهير اليوم
الشعر
اخفر السبا اليوم ان ي
القما من جعل اليوم
السيد هذه الاصلاحات يا رجل في عهد هذا
الرجل 40 مليون دول ض المفسدين من اجل
الكهرباء والشعب العراقي يعيش في ظلام دعم
اليس كذا نعم نعم نعم مليارات 40 مليار
دعم اقوللك اقول لك استاذ جمال استاذ جمال
استاذ جمال استاذ جمال الجماهير الشعب
العراقي بكل مدنه من البصره الى بغداد ثار
بوجه الفساد ثار بوجه الطبقه السياسيه
الفاشله ثار بوجه الوزراء الفاشلين وقد
اسقطت سقطت الرؤوس الكبيره اليوم كل هذه
الرؤوس راينا البعض خرج العراقي يري تق
العود هل ه
را داود هو يقول لك انه حق ان الرجل ان
يعود بالخ لم يسقط شيء اولا لم يسقط شيء
وان لو سمحت لو سمحت يا سيد علاء انتظر ما
حصل مجرد واجهه واجهه ديكور ديكور لا يعبر
عن عن واقع التغيير الحقيقي واقع التغيير
الحقيقي يبدا باجراءات ميدانيه على الارض
هذه الاجراءات تبدا بحاله المفسدين
والمعروفه اسمائهم وعناوينهم الى
المحاكمات فورا وليس عبر التحقيق البسيط
الذي لا يعني اي شي س حاسب من السلطه
القضائيه فاسده في العراق مدحت المحمود
اللي هو رئيس جهاز القضاء العلى اكبر مفسد
المشكله في العراق هل هو مسيطر عليه هذا
القضاء من المالك طبعا مسيطر عليه من نور
المالكي نور المالكي يملك امبراطوريه ما
فيوزيه تحكم العراق من خلال مؤسستين
الامنيه والعسكريه وحتى من خلال المؤسسه
القضائيه السنوات التي قضاها نور المالكي
من 2006 الى 2014 بالسلطه وفرت له قاعده
وثم ان الرجل رجل استخباري رجل عمل مع
مخابرات دوليه رجل عمل مع المخابرات
السوريه مع المخابرات الايرانيه مارس
الارهاب في الشرق الاوسط يعرف جيدا كيف
يتصرف ويعرف جيدا كيف يبني مناطق نفوذ
الان الجماهير العراقيه للاسف
متذبذبه الاعراء والاتجاهات حتى المليشيات
الارهابيه دخلت وايدت هذه التظاهرات مثل
جماعه عصاب الحق اللي قوتها الخزعلي جماعه
ارهابيه هذه معروفه مارسته الارهاب ضد
القوات الدوليه او مارس الارهاب ضد الشعب
العراقي ومارست عمليات القتل
الطائفي طيب انت م تقول
مقاومه جماعه
نا الحشد الشعبي لم
يق
الش الشبت ممره من
المرجعيه يق اي ش داعش مسيطره على 40% او
35 من
العرا داود انت تعطيه شماعه الكل يعلقها
على الشماعه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
العراقيون الحكومه العراقيه تقول ذلك تقول
سبب المصائب في الميزانيه العراقيه انها
تنفق تنظم الدول الايه داعش ارهابيه ل مو
ارهابيه داعش وماع كذلك اللي هي جماعه
جماعه الاحزاب الشيعيه الطائفيه لا ليس
داعش هذا من جانب واحد داعش خلقها نور
المالكي وخلقها بشار الاسد وخلقها التحالف
الايراني داعش معروف لا
ت هل تنظيم داعش هل تنظيم داعش تنظيم
ارهابي وجك يا اخي لو سمح يا سيد داوود
سيد داود سيد علاء اين لا تخلط الاوراق
تخلط الاوراق عفوا الان ناتي للمال اين
اموال العراق اسمحلي عندي سؤال يا رجل
بيجي يا اخي في وقت ت انتظر اين اموال
العراق لماذا نهبت خزائن
العراق اين اين اموال العراق اين نهبت
اموال
الس السؤال استذ نعم لك لك سيد علاء ا نعم
استاذ استاذ جمال شوف نحن نعترف الان
جميعا ان هناك فساد وهناك سراق لذلك قامت
هذه المظاهرات هذه المظاهرات لم تاتي عبث
لذلك ما وصفتها انها هبه او انها محركه من
قبل جهات معينه سياسيه هذا حقيقه منافي
للحقيقه ومنافي للواقع الواقع ان الجماهير
والشعب الع
قد سام من هذه الطبقه وسام من السراق وهو
يعيش في حاله مزريه والواقع العراقي واقع
مزر يا سيدي لكن اقول لك بان العراقيون
عندما خرجوا الى المدن بهذه التظاهرات
الحضاريه السلميه ارادوا ان يسقطوا كل
الفاسدين والسراق وبالنتيجه هذه الا
تحثه الا تحدث
عن تحاول ركوب الموجه من خلال اعلان
تاييدها لمطالب المحتجين بهدف احداث
انقسام بينهم ما
رايك نعم ما سمعت السؤال سيد جمال و انت
لا تترك لي مجال لكي اسال اقول لك بان
التيارات الدينيه والسياسيه تحاول ركوب
الموجه من خلال اعلاها تاييدها لمطالب
المحتجين بهدف احداث انقسام بينهم يعني
الكل يبحث عن مصلحته لا يا سيدي ال الشباب
العراقي شباب واعي من نزل الى ساحات
التظاهر كانوا واعين تماما ب هذه القضيه
لذلك رفضوا وجود اي سياسي حتى السياسيين
العلمانيين حتى السياسيين العلمانيين ومن
التيارات المدنيه رفضوا تواجدهم في ساحات
التظاهر لان هذا يشوه مطالب المتظاهرين
وبالتالي حاول البعض من الاحزاب السياسيه
في العراق ركوب الموجه الا ان الشباب
العراقي كان واعيا
لهذا الفعل واخرجهم تماما خارج الساحات
وبالنتيجه اليوم من يتظاهر في داخل هذه
الساعات هم الفقراء وهم الحقيقه الذين
يتوقون الى الحريه ويتوقون الى التغيير
الذي ينادي به المجتمع العراقي برمته طيب
سيد سيد سيد داوود البعض يقول بان ما يجري
حاليا في العراق مجرد لعبه سياسيه يقودها
لوردات الفساد ضد بعضهم بعض هل تراها فعلا
كذلك ام هي هبه عابره مثلا لا هي متنوعه
هنالك العاب هنالك العاب فعلا هنالك
الطبقه السياسيه الف في العراق افسدت
كثيرا ودمرت الوضع واصبحت مواقعها مواقعها
مهدده بالكامل لانها مهدده بفقدان السلطه
مهدده حتى فقدان الحياه العراق الان يعيش
في وضع خاص صعب جدا وفي منعطف تاريخي لذلك
كانت هذه التظاهرات ضروريه جدا ضروريه
واكثر من ضروريه من اجل اعطاء بعض الحيويه
للحياه السياسيه ومن ومن اجل ايضا التغلب
على مخاطر حقيقيه تواجه حكومه حيدر
العبادي حكومه حذر العبادي من خلال
العمليات الاخيره الفاشله في الفلوجه وفي
محور الانبار هددت من قبل مليشيات المسلحه
هددت من قبل جماعه الخزعلي عصاب الحق
وهددت من قبل
جماعه جماعه بدر هددت بالقيام بانقلاب
باعتبار ان العبادي ضعيف كما قال الخزعلي
وقال ان العمليه السياسيه لابد لا يمكن ان
تستمر بهذه الطريقه هذا يعني ان هنالك
صراع داخل التحالف الشيعي صراع بنيوي بين
من ومن بين بين الاحزاب الشيعيه انفسهم
والمالكي توارى عن الظل حينما عين نائبا ل
الرئيس وتوافق العراقيون على حيدر العبادي
رئيس للحكومه العراقيه
الجديده لماذا تدهورت الاوضاع ذهب الرجل
وجاء شخص اخر المالكي يحرك الخيوط وحيدر
العبادي انسان ضعيف شخص ضعيف حتى على
مستوى حزب الدعوه ليس له قاعده جماهيريه
كما يقول كما يقول احد سيا حزب الدعوه
اللي هو عزه الشابندر يقول عزه الشاهبندر
اللي هو احد قيادات حزب الدعوه التاريخيين
المعروفين يقول عن حيدر العباد انه اغبى
واحد اغبى عنصر في حزب الدعوه ثم ان الرجل
لا يملك اي سلطه حقيقيه السلطه الحقيقيه
صم الام الموجوده في النج هنالك الطه
الحقيقيه حتى التظاهرات حتى التظاهرات
هناك تنسيق تنسيق ما بين الحكومه العراقيه
بين رئيس الحكومه العراقيه وما بين
المرجعيه الدينيه ال سيد علاء سيد علاء
البعض يقول لكي يصلح العراق لا بد ان يكون
قراره مستقلا بمعنى الانسلاخ عن ايران هل
العراقيين العراقيون مستعدون فعلا لكي
يستقلوا في قرارهم ان يبتعدوا عن القرار
الايراني دعني اقول لك شيء مهم جدا يا سيد
جمال اولا من يصف السيد حيدر العبادي
بالضعف في الحقيقه لا يعرف شخصيه السيد
العبادي تماما وهذا يذكرني حقيقه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي عندما عينت موجريني وعينت اشتن
وقالوا عنهن ان شخصيات ضعيفه ولا يستطعن
ان يواصلن العمل باعتبارهن شخصيات ضعيفه
ولكن في الحقيقه موجريني التي قادت
المفاوضات مع مع ايران واثبتت بانها شخصيه
قويه هذا الكلام حقيقه قد يعني طبل له
الاعلام كثيرا بان السيد حيدر العبادي
شخصيه ضعيفه لا السيد حيدر العبادي شخصيه
قويه وشخصيه قادره واليوم قد حصل على
تفويض شعبي وتفويض من المرجعيه محاربه
الفساد انا لا اريدك ان تلمع شخص على حساب
انا لا اريدك ان تلمع شخص على حساب شعب
بكامله لا نريد ايضا ان نظلل
المشاهد القرار لوحده هو مستعد فعلا هل هو
مستعد فعلا صاء كل الفاسدين في العراق هل
يستطيع التحرش بنور المالك يا سيد جمال
انت كيف كيف زين طيب انت كيف سمحت الان
لضيفك بان يقول بانه شخصيه ضعيفه ولن ترد
وحينما من يقول قيس الخزعلي لست انا من
يقول اهل التحالف الشيعي نفسه يقول لست
انا ليس
راغ وعزه الشهبندر يقول وليس انا نفس
السياسيين اللي من حزب الدعوه لست انا
وشهد شاهد من اهلها لا بهيب جاوب على
السؤال يا سيدي جاوب يا سيد علا السؤال
شخص لا يعمم
ص انت تعرف
القضيه لا تريد ان تجاوب عن السؤال هل
تستطيع ان تجاوب على السؤال هل يستطيع
العبادي ان يكون مستقلا بقراره بعيدا عن
المالكي
والفاسدين نعم نعم اقول لك انه العبادي
الان سيحقق ما لا ت وروه ابدا السيد
العبادي انا لا المع السيد العبادي لعلمك
لا الم المع السيد العبادي ولا يحتاج
السيد العبادي من عندي تلميع لان هو رئيس
وزراء انا ايش عندي حتى يكون المع السيد
العبادي يا سيدي اولا السيد العبادي بما
انه حصل على تفويض
الشعب ويجب ان يكون شجاعا والا على السيد
العبادي اذا لم يكن في في في في يعني
مستوى المسؤوليه ومستوى هذه المرحله عليه
ان يخرج الى الشعب العراقي اذا كانت هناك
اي عرقلات من قبل الاحزاب والكتل السياسيه
والشخصيات النافذه التي تضررت بسبب هذه
المظاهرات ووقفت بوجه السيد العبادي على
السيد العبادي ان يظهر على شاشات
التلفزيون ويفضح هؤلاء امام الشعب العراقي
اليوم الشعب العراقي يقف مع السيد العبادي
اليوم الشعب العراقي والمرجعيه كلهم
يباركون خطوات السيد العبادي لا لكون
السيد العبادي اليوم لشخص ابدا لكون هو
الذي يحقق هذه القضيه ويبقى سيد الدي هو
خادم هذا الشعب وهو موظف خدمه عامه تفضل
اتمنى فعلا ان يكون عبادي بمستوى
المسؤوليه واتمنى ان يكون حد العبادي
بمستوى المسؤوليه اللي يتحدث عن الاخ علاء
لكن لو كان الحيدر العبادي جادا عليه خطوه
اولى واساسيه ومركز ان ينسحب من حزب
الدعوه ليكون رئيسا لكل العراق وليس لحزب
او لفئه معينه من العراقيين تحدث هو عن
الجماهير المحتج اين هذا الشعب العراقي
يتكلم عن نصف الشعب العراقي بينما اهم
النصف الاخر الذي كان في طليعه الانتفاضه
عام 2013 والذي اهدر المالكي ماه في
الحويجه وغير الحويجه والذي شن عليه حملات
عباده ولا زالت هذه الحملات مستمره ضد
الفلوجه وضد الانبار وضد الرمادي وضد كل
مكان حيدر العبادي اتمنى ان يكون بنفس
المواصفات لكن مع الاسف حيدر العبادي مجرد
بدل فاقد بدل فاقد يحاول حل ازمه السلطه
لا اكثر ولا اقل حيدر العبادي مجرد وجه
بشوش حقيقي ذو نفسيه طيبه لكن اعتقد شهاده
الاستاذ الصحفي المعروف وشيخ البرلمان كان
اللي هو حسن ال علوي وصف بالوصف دقيق قال
حد بادي مثل خشب المرفع لا يظر ولا ينفع
هذا يعني انه لن يستطيع ان ان يفعل اي شيء
لن يستطيع ان يستمر هل معنى ذلك ان العراق
بحاجه الى اعاده تجديد للعمليه السياسيه
بحاجه الى قياده جديده تكنوقراطيه بحاجه
الى قياده وطنيه حقيقيه بحاجه العراق الان
يسير الجماهير العراقيه تسير في الطريق
الصحيح تسير في طريق الغاء ال طائفيه
سياسيه تسير في طريق التحضر والدوله
المدنيه لكن هذا يحتاج الى مقاومه وتضحيات
دمويه المليشيات والعصابات الطائفيه لن
تسكت هي الان تحت الارض كي كيف يمكن تحقيق
كل ما تفضلت به والعراق مشتت الان ممزق
يقولون حروب قتل ي كل يوم تقريبا بالعشرات
تجميد العمل بالدستور الناس بدون كهرباء
تجميد العمل بالدستور حل البرلمان اقامت
حكومه انقاذ وطني من تكنوقراط
وتكليف المجتمع الدولي برعايه الحكومه
حقيقه نحن بحاجه لرعايه دوليه التغيير
عندما جاء في العراق لم يكن اراده الشعب
العراقي عندما اسقط النظام السابق لم تكن
بايد الشعب العراقي اسقطه بعيدي القوات
الامريكيه وهذه حقيقه لو لم تقم الولايات
المتحده لكن حينما تقول بحاجه الى رعايه
دوليه يعني انت تريد تدويل تدويل النزاع
في الراق نعم نعم لان العراقيين عاجزين عن
حل مشاكلهم بانفسهم لان هنالك الصراعات
هنالك الطرف الخبيث الايراني يدخل بكل قوه
مثلا رئيس الاركان الايراني حسن فيروز
ابادي قال
التظاهرات يدها الكفار واعداء الاسلام ما
هذا الكلام كيف يسمح رئيس الاركان
الايراني هذا الوسخ ان يصب العراقين لا
تستعمل يقول ما يقولون
انتت
بكربلا طيب خليه السؤ الرا العام تضليل
الرا
العاملان استغفر الله العظيم لا تضليل
تضليل للراي العام انت انت لم تتابع اذا
لم تتابع لو كنت متابع بشكل صحيح لرايت ان
الجماهير التي خرجت في النجف نادت بشكل
واضح جدا وبشعار واضحه جدا انها ضد الطبقه
السياسيه وضد بعض رجال الدين وكذلك ما حدث
في كربلاء وهن مدينتان مقدستان هاتين
المدينتين المقدستين لدى الشيعه في العراق
فيها يكون في هذا في هذا الظرف هذه
الشعارات يجب عليك ان تكون هل ستطيع
التغير هل تستطيع عده الاف ان تغير الضع
السياسي عده الاف م
انت لا تستهين الان تناق تناق
حكنا السياسيه الداخليه هشه بالكامل هنك
قو شعيه هنالك تيارات
هصات تم
الس انت قلت ان الم يريدون
التير قبل شويه قلت ان هؤلاء لا يمكن انه
يرتج من عندهم شيء يعني انا ما اعرف طيب
اذا ما هو المطلوب سيد علاء سيد علاء اذا
ما هو المطلوب يعني لماذا حيدر العبادي
السيد رئيس وزراء العراق لا يدعو الى حوار
وطني شامل بدون اقصاء لاحد وكما قال السيد
داوود مصالحه وطنيه العيب في ذلك ماذا
ماذا تقصد بالاقصاء ماذا تقصد باقصاء احد
يعني شنو اقصاء احد خلي هناك كثيرون من
السنه هناك كثيرون من
السنه غير راضين غير را من
من الغالبيه
السنيه كثيرون من الشيعه غير راضين وهناك
كثير من الشيعه غير راض مومين الشيعه ايض
مظلومين فعلا اليوم اللي انتفضوا انتفضوا
شيعه لكن الشيعه تحر المراجع مع
الاسي انتت انتف الشيعيه ما انتف سنيه
الراي العام الشيعي والرا الشعب
الشيع سياسي سني اجاه المظاهرات مشكله
الشيعه انهم تحت سيطره عمائم هذ مشكله
الشينيه السياسيه النجفي سني لكنه من سنه
السلطه عزيزي ولا يختلف فساد عن فساد
الاخرين ال لا
تقولي اج ما هو دور هؤلاء ايام المعارضه
يا
سيديم المارضه هم نفس يعني احنا ما عندنا
غير داعش وغير ذ ما عندنا غير داعش وغير
ذول شن اجيبلك داعش سيد يا سيد يا سيد
علاء لماذا تاخر حيدر العبادي كل هذا
الوقت يعني ربما ان هذه الاصلاحات التي
اصدرها وقر البرلمان لم لن يتم البت فيها
ربما لن تضي الى شي سي جمال سي جمال انت
رجل اعلامي اسمح لي يا سيد جمال خب يا ر
واعلامي كبير استغفر الله خليني اجاوبك يا
سيد جمال وانت رجل يعني اعلامي كبير هل من
المعقول ان تطلق لي هذا السؤال والسيد
العبادي قبل التظاهرات اطلق حزمه حقيقه من
القرارات في قضيه القطع المبرمج وقبلها
الحمايات اخي محاربه
الفساد محاسبه المحاربه الفساد هو كشف
يعني هو ما ما
حاسس القيادات العسر يطلق تصريحات يتهجم
فيها على دول عربيه ودوله عربيه كبيره مثل
السعوديه ما مصلحته ان يقول ذلك يوجد رئيس
حكومه جيد جيد جيد
اسمحلي وشنو يعني يعني اسمح لي يعني ليش
هذا هذا التصريح هو مو بس من المالكيه هو
تصريح كثير من الدول تصرح هذا التصريح شو
علاقه
الموضوع هذا التصريح الق حكومه في اسمها
حكومه حيدررر
العبادي زين طيب يا سيدي الحكومه السعوديه
يوميه حزم تصاريح تطلعنا ضد الشعب العراقي
وزنا ارهابيين ودز لنا مثقفات وتدعم
المجموعات الارهابيه وهذا كل السييد داوود
يقولك قبل قليل الوضع في العراق بحاجه الى
رعايه دوليه المال ذهب بعيدا وراح وقال
السعوديه يجب وضعها تحت الوصايا ما علاقه
هذا الرجل في الموضوع يا رجل هو
يخ نحن نحن من نؤسس لهذه الدوله نح لسنا
بقاصرين نحن من نؤسس هذه الدوله ونحن شعب
ذو تاريخ عريق احنا عندنا تاريخ وعندنا
تراكم وعندنا خبرات وعندنا كفاءات كل هذا
موجود في العراق وانتم تشدون كل العرب
يشدون بذلك انا لا اقول شيء من الفرا
عزيزي النتيجه اسمحوا لنا اسمحوا لنا
ادعموا ادعموا العراق ادعموا المتظاهرين
ادعموا الخط الاصلاحي ادعموا من يريد ان
يلغي المحاصصه ادعموا من يريد التغيير
ادعموا من يريد ازاله الوجوه الكالحه
ادعموا من يريد ان يزيل هذه الطبقه
السياسيه الفاشله فاسده فاسده وليست فاشله
فقط فاسده وفاشله فاسده والفاسده انا
والفاسده اتفق معك اتفق معك هي فاسده اذا
تغير
ولكن لا لا تعزف على الوتر الطائفي لا لا
لا لا اوكي ننسى الموضوع الطائفي نحن لا
نثير طائفيه هنا انت تصر على انه خص
اتفقنا اذن اتفقنا استاذ جمال اتفقنا انت
تصر على انه هذه التظاهرات وهذه الاصلاحات
ليس هدفها النظام السياسي هذا كلام خطير
يا
سيدي لا يا سيدي انا اقول ان النظام
الديمقراطي هو نظام خيار الشعب العراقي
العراقيون لا يريدون ان يرجعوا الى
الدكتاتوريه هذا ما اقوله اما ان يغيروا
من نظام برلماني الى رئاسي فهذا شان
العراقيين ارجوكم ارجوكم ثم ارجوكم
واقولها بكل صراحه العراقيون هم اصحاب
الشير من نظام الى نظام اسمحلي اخ علاء
انت الان في لندن وبالقرب من عندك وجارك
الان واحد من اكبر الحراميه واللصوص ومن
حزب الدعوه اللي هو عبد الفلاح
السوداني اللي سرق مليار دولار التجاره هل
يستطيع العبادي اسمحلي خلي اكمل سؤالي هل
يستطيع العبادي مثلا ان يطلب
انت لا على شخصيات انا علا
ب الشخصيات هذه الشخصيات من الذي وضعها
ير الذي وضع هذه الشخصيات غير
المالك البنامج المالكي هو البرنامج على
المالكي يا سيدي وع التظاهرات هو اصل
الفساد وراس
الف الاصلاحات وعلى حيدر العبادي هل تم
اعتقال
المالكي تي على لا يجر لا يجر حيدر
العبادي مجرد ظاهره صوتيه لا اكثر ولا اقل
طيب انت انتم ايضا ظاهره صوتيه الى متى تب
هكذا
تصرخون الجماهير عبر من يمد يده للحوار في
العراق الجميع يمد يده ماد السلطه السلطه
متاثره بالقرارات الايرانيه لا تستطيع ان
تتصرف بخطوه واحده بدون موافقه ايران ربما
ربما ايران غيرت وبدلت يقال انها تغير
الان في متعلق باليمن في سوريا ربما انها
ت يتعلق وينان بمظاهرات
لبنان ف وبسبب الاتفاق النووي الامريكي
الغربي ايران الان في حاله سكون لكن سكون
خارجي لكنها في الداخل تعمل وتنسخ وتستعد
لليوم الايراني الموعود تستعد ليوم اطلاق
المليشيات العقون بالاير فوبيا وانا اراه
لا لا لا ليس ايران فوبيا الحرس الثوري
وسليماني
اين مسكون انت مسكون
فوبيا انا شو اسويلك
يعني اقوللك اسمح لي وجود ابو م يا سي دا
انا اقوللك يا سيج م س يا سيد
دا المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا في المدن
العراقيه لا علاقه لهم بايتم الالتفاف على
مطالبهم سيتم الفاف على مطالبهم سيتم
النظام خ القراء ه الين خرج تح عقليه
فارسيه خبيثه من يخطط في العراق عقليه
فارسيه خبيثه عقليه صميه عقليه مرجعيه وان
ت هذا الخطاب و
فرقعه صوتيه بالون اختبار ليس اكثر الهدف
الرئيسي الان اجها الانتفاضه اج الانتفاضه
كيف من خلال الالتفاف على
المطال ما لم نرى اجراءات ميدانيه حقيقيه
باحاله الفاس باحاله الفاس الى محاكم
ومحاكم فوريه وتنفذ الاحكام فوريه
ف يقول في كل اسبوع راح تغير يعني تغيير
بالتقسيط المريح هل هذا اسلوب كيف يك كل
اسبوع اظ القرار هذا اسلوب غريب يعني
الفاس يعني شنو رايك انت شنو رايك شو شو
شو نسوي يعني واحنا عندنا حرب مع داعش
والارهابيين شو نس سيد علاء يعني هذه هذه
القرارات الان التي
اصدرها رئيس الوزراء العراقي اقرت من
البرلمان لماذا لا تباركها ربما انه ينتهج
الطريق الصحيح وياخذ العراق و من هذه
المستنقع الذي وقع نباركها لو انها لم
تاتي بعد سنوات من المعاناه نباركها لو ان
هذا البرلمان قبل الانتخابات الاخيره قد
عبر عن هذا الشيء نبارك لو انه فعلا كانت
استجابه حقيقيه من الحكومه من اجل رفع
المعانات عن الجماهير لكن الحكومه مهزومه
الحكومه مفلسه العراق النفطي يستدين من
صندوق النقد الدولي حاله حال بوركينا فاسو
هل هذا معقول يعني اين ذهبت اموال البترول
ميزانيه العراق تقدر بميزانيات خمس دول
عربيه سوريا ولبنان وحتى الكويت وياها
تصور اين ذهبت هذه الاموال من حق الانسان
ان يتساءل البرلمان مجرد بالوعه لمص شفط
الاموال واحد يسوي باسي تذهب هذه الاموال
تخرج خارج العراق طبعا تخرج خارج العراق
الان زعماء العمليه السياسيه وق العمليه
السياسيه وحتى الوزراء اصبحوا من كبار من
اللوردات اشتروا اموال اشتروا املاك في
دبي وفي لندن وفي كل مكان في العالم ب
العر هل تمول اسلحه شراء اسلحه وحروب في
دول مجاوره لا لا ليس شراء اسلحه وان
مستعمله استعمالات الشخصيه خاصه باعتبار
ان امراء
الفساد من اهل البطوله التي جاعت ثم شبعت
الجماعه الجماعه اللي اجت من السلطه كانوا
حفات حفات عرات من تفين بطون جاعت ثم شبعت
وما صدقت بالمثل العراقي يقول مخرو يا
حبيبي لا لا لا لا
تلا وابوه كان رئيس عزاء
القدريه لا اشمل الجميع اشمل الجميع جميع
المرتبطين بالعمليه السياسيه سنه وشيعه
حرام سنه وشيعه لا ابر احدا لا ابر احلا
حيدر العبادي حاف شان لا ليس ماذا كان
موظف كهرباء في لندن انا اتكلم عن اخرين
ما اتكلم عن حيدر يعني ه الحكومه م حيدر
حيدر حدر
مجون ليو مجون
رم انا اقلك مسؤوليتي مريض نفسي متقاعد
لاسباب نفسيه انا لاجئ واعرف ماذا
متحدى ان يثبت
العكس الان بقي لنا دقائق وانا يعني احب
في هذه الحلقه ان نطرح سؤال مهم جدا الى
متى يبقى العراق هكذا متى يتصالح
العراقيون مع انفسهم متى يتوقف العراقي عن
اقصاء العراق الاخر متى يتوقف نهب العراق
وانزلاق نحو المجهول مر العراق بسنوات
اجاف يا سيد علاء ويا سيد داوود نعم هل
انتم اثنان شخصيا هل انتم مستعدان
للتصالح كل واحد يبعث بوسي للثانيه ليس
هناك مشكله شخصيه بالعكس ليس ابعث لي الف
قبله ليس عندي مشكله في هذا الموضوع انا
اتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه فا عندي مشكله
شخصيه هو صديق ما له علاقه ابدا ما في اي
مشكله خاصه لكن لا هو مستفيد ولا انا
مستفيد لا هو حرامي ولا انا حرامي لا هو
من من جماعه السلطه اللي اللي شفط فلوس
بالعكس هو الرجل عايش في لندن عادي يعني
وانا عايش في اوسلو عادي لا اكثر ولا اقل
لكن لكن لكن المساله با اختلاف وجهات
النظر هو يدافع عن النظام انا اراه نظام
فاسد حتى العظم حتى النقاع لا يمكن عنظام
النظام السياسي الجماهير خ ضد النظام
السياسي هذه الرئيسيه ضد النظام السياس ضد
البرمان
الحرام العراقيه اع عن المجتمع العراقي عن
العراقيين
المظلومين لس لي د سيبقون
مظلومين ل
دك قوه شيطانيه خربت العراق الولايات
المتحده اولا وايران ثانيا وايران لازالت
تعمل وستحاول فعل انقلاب ميليشياوي دموي
والايام بيننا وانظر الى الايام القريبه
طيب سيد علاء يعني هل انت مستعد لارسال
قبله ل ابن بلدك ودمك ولحمك داود
البصري الف قبله على جبينه ليش اريد اريد
قبله اريد ان اشاهد يدك تقبل هذا الرجل
هذا عراقي لا هل ت قبله الى الى داود ليس
عندي مشكله ليس عندي مشكله هذه القبله
رساله لكل لكل العراق يعني الاخ صديق عزيز
يعني من اجل ان يكون العراق مستقل سيدي
اقوللك بعيد عن تدخلات خارجيه استذ جمال
ان ان يتوقف العراق عن النا لا احد
لا يا استاذ جمال والله العظيم ليس هناك
عراقي شريف وليس هناك انسان في هذا البلد
عاش وشرب من نهر دجله والفرات الا وان رضع
الطيبه من حليب امه والله العظيم هذا
البلد بلد عظيم وبلد كبير وبلد ذو تاريخ
وحضاره وناس طيبون واهل كرم لكن جار عليه
الزمن وجار عليه حقيقه بعض الاخوه ونحن
الان كيوسف في في ما بين اخوته وبين
المجتمع الاقليمي وبين المجتمع الدولي
لدينا نقمه اسمها النفط يا جماعه والله
لدينا نقمه اسمها النفط لولا النفط وهذه
الاموال لما وضع صار الع بهذا الوضع اليوم
والله العظيم اقول لك وانا اصرخ العراقيون
يستغيثون من الحر يستغيثون من قله الخدمات
يستقذر من كثير من القضايا التي حقيقه
تنغص عيشهم لا يمكن ان نختلف ونحن
كعراقيين نختلف مع في ما بيننا على قضيه
وطنيه الا ان نكون مدفوعون من قبل اجندات
اجنبيه الذي لا يدفع من قبل اجنده اجنبيه
او انه لديه حقيقه غرض في ان يسرق لا يمكن
ان يختلف على الوطن او يختلف على عراق ط
سيد داوود كلمه اخيره علينا ان لا نحمل
اخي المسؤوليه ولا نحمل اي طرف المسؤوليه
المسؤوليه المسؤوليه عراقيه بحته القرار
العراقي مع الاسف كان قرار ليس بيد الشعب
العراقي وانما بيد اراده
دوليه جباره هي التي دمرت العراق والان
تساهم ايضا في تدمير العراق وتتفرج على ال
المماسات العراقيه والان القوى الاقليميه
الكبرى في المنطقه وايران هي التي تهيم
الاسف على القر العراقي بسبب القوى
السياسيه العميله الكسيحه التي ينبغي
ازاحتها وهذه فرصه تاريخيه للشعب العراقي
لكي يزيح هذه الفئه العميله لانها لو لو
تتجاوز هذه الفرصه فلم تكن هناك فرصه اخرى
العراق في طريق الدمار والتغيير والتقسيم
ما لم تتم طرد المجرمين هذه الحقيقه
واللصوص والحراميه عبر اجراءات فعليه
تقديم للمحاكمه وعبر المحاسبه الحقيقيه
والقانونيه اما ما عدا ذلك فليس وهم وسراب
وهروب الى الامام نشكر الباحث السيد داوود
البصري الكاتب والباحث السياسي كذلك نشكر
في لندن الكاتب والاعلامي علاء الخطيب
مشاهدينا الكرام تحيه لكم من قناه الجزيره
في قطر وفي الاسبوع القادم موعدكم مع
الزميل فيصل قاسم تحيه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء